.
>> Tammy: PERFECT.
GREAT JOB AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SHARING IT WITH US.
NOW, WE ARE LEARNING NEW
INFORMATION ABOUT THE GRUESOME
BEHEADING OF A WOMAN NEAR
MINNEAPOLIS THIS WEEK AND WHY
THE ALLEGED KILLER WAS FREE TO
WALK THE STREETS IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
TODAY POLICE CHARGING ALEXIS
WITH SECOND DEGREE INTENTIONAL
MURDER FOR HIS ROLE IN THE DEATH
OF.
LOCAL REPORT SUGGEST HE WAS
RELEASED ON BOND THIS SPRING
AFTER ALLEGEDLY TRYING TO BURN
DOWN HIS APARTMENT IN 2020 JUST
THREE YEARS AFTER HE WAS
CONVICTED OF DOMESTIC ASSAULT
CHARGES IN 2017.
HERE NOW RADIO HOST AND
EDITORIAL DIRECTOR OF THE DAILY
CALLER, A VERY BUSY MAN.
GREAT STORY AT THE DAILY CALLER
COVERING THIS THESE ARE THE
THINGS THAT AMERICANS NEED TO
KNOW ABOUT WHAT IS TRANSPIRING
IN GREAT AMERICAN CITIES.
GIVE US A PICTURE ABOUT WHY THIS
IS EVEN POSSIBLE RIGHT NOW.
>> YEAH, WHEN WE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT CRIME, A LOT OF FOCUS IS,
OF COURSE, PLACED ON THE POLICE.
IT'S NOT JUST THE POLICE IN OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
NEEDS TO WORK.
IT'S THE PROSECUTORS AND COURTS
AS WELL.
AND THIS BEHEADING THIS WEEK IS
GOING TO PLACE A LOT OF FOCUS ON
THE COURT THAT RELEASED THIS
GUY.
ULTIMATELY HE HAS A COUPLE OF
CONVICTIONS IN HIS PAST.
ONE OF THEM FOR DOMESTIC ABUSE.
THE INITIALS MATCH UP WITH
AMERICA -- PROBABLY HE
DOMESTICALLY ABUSED HER IN 2017
BEFORE HE SUBSEQUENTLY NOW
MURDERED HER.
AS YOU MENTIONED HE APPARENTLY
TRIED TO SET FIRE TO HIS OWN
APARTMENT LAST YEAR AND THAT LED
TO A COURT HEARING THIS SPRING
WHERE A COURT DOCTOR RECOMMENDED
THAT HE BE TAKEN INTO CUSTODY
AND HELD THERE BECAUSE HE IS A
THREAT TO THE COMMUNITY.
THE JUDGE RELEASED HIM AND NOW
THIS IS THE RESULT.
>> Tammy: WOULD YOU SAY, I MEAN,
IT SEEMS TO BE CLEAR THAT THE
RHETORIC THAT IS COMING OUT OF
WASHINGTON OUT OF CERTAIN
POLITICIANS THE DEFUND THE
POLICE MOVEMENT, THIS REJECTION
OF JUSTICE AND REPERCUSSIONS AND
RESPONSIBILITY THAT THIS IS WHAT
IS DRIVING THIS WOULD YOU AGREE
WITH THAT?
>> A CONSEQUENCE-FREE WORLD IS A
WORLD IN WHICH CRIMINALS THRIVE.
THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE CREATED.
I NEAR IN D.C., NYIAH COURTNEY 6
YEARS OLD KILLED TWO FRIDAYS AGO
NOW KILLED IN D.C. GUNNED DOWN
IN THE MIDDLE YOU HAVE THE
NIGHT.
THE PERSON WHO KILLED HER
ALREADY WAS IN TROUBLE IN
MARYLAND THIS PAST YEAR FOR AN
ILLEGAL WEAPONS CHARGE AND GRAND
THEFT AUTO.
THIS IS TYPICAL.
THESE ARE CRIMINALS WHO GET
RELEASED BACK INTO THE PUBLIC.
AND THEN GO ON TO COMMIT HEINOUS
ACTS OF VIOLENCE.
>> Tammy: YOU KNOW, AND PEOPLE
THINK -- SOME PEOPLE ARE BEING
TOLD OR BELIEVE THIS IS JUST
SOME NATURAL PROGRESSION OF EVIL
AMERICA.
THIS IS THE RESULT OF POLICY AS
WELL.
IT'S A RESULT OF RHETORIC
WHETHER THEY CAN'T -- OH, WE'RE
NOT GOING TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
THE RHETORIC HAS MADE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE POLICE TO DO
THEIR JOB.
SO THE POLICE RESIGN OR MOVE ON
TO SOME OTHER CAREER OR THEY
QUIT OR WHATEVER THEY DO.
BUT THIS IS THE END RESULT OF
THE DEMOCRATIC MINDSET.
IT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY
DEVELOPMENT AND IT'S AFFECTING
EVERY CITY, NOT JUST BLUE CITIES
AT THIS POINT.
>> AND IT'S THE PRODUCT OF
DEMOCRATS WHO DON'T FEEL THAT
THEY NEED TO ACTUALLY CHANGE THE
LAWS IN ORDER TO CHANGE WHAT THE
LAWS ARE.
>> Tammy: YES.
>> YOU ARE LOOKING AT DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS, STATES ATTORNEYS,
COMMONWEALTH ATTORNEYS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY BEING PUT INTO PLACE
BY WEALTHY LIBERAL DONORS LIKE
GEORGE SOROS DEFINITELY BANK
ROLLED THESE TYPES OF CAMPAIGNS
IN ORDER GET THESE GUYS TO NOT
PROSECUTE CRIMES.
IT'S A BIG DEAL.
>> Tammy: THIS IS AN AGENDA.
IT'S PLANNED.